A few months ago, I had a brilliant
idea: I’d make a tribal gates deck,
with Child of Alara as the commander. I’d run
55 lands along with a bunch of draw and ramp,
with Maze’s End, Crackling Perimeter, and a
handful of beatdown options being my wincons.
A plethora of ways to sacrifice Child of Alara
means that I should have board control mostly
handled, so I only need a mere five slots of
the deck dedicated to interaction of all types.
How efficient. Finally, a few options for big
lifegain means that once my land count is up
where I want it, I can heal up the damage it took
me to get there. It’s not a high-caliber deck,
but it certainly scratched my goofy-deck itch,
and it seemed pretty solid for what it was.
Unfortunately it was a terrible idea,
chiefly because of the commander.
Now, allow me to lay my credentials on
the table. I am a cruel control player
at heart. My first commander deck was mono black
ruin-your-day with Sheoldred as the commander.
My first deck I played with at sanctioned
events was a standard Grixis control deck
I built just after the release of Born of the
Gods. And my favorite draft I ever played in
was a Dragons of Tarkir draft where I picked up
five flattens and seven other removal spells,
and spent my night gleefully watching the joy
drain from my opponents’ eyes as creature after
creature bit the dust immediately after it was
played. So when I tell you I want a commander
that just repetitively boardwipes to be a good
idea, I mean it. But it’s not a good idea.
In the context of commander, boardwipes are a
type of effect that I would call “asymmetric”.
This is confusing on the surface, since they’re
generally literally symmetrical effects—you
know, they destroy everything. But what
I mean here is that they impact different
players massively differently. Somebody playing a
low-mid power synergistic midrange deck will feel
them very brutally, but there are a lot of types
of decks that just won’t really care as much.
Board wipes won’t stop combos, they won’t
prevent aggro decks from abusing your life total,
they won’t slow down large land counts, and they
won’t shut down your opponents generating a lot
of instant and sorcery-based value. The best
option my Child of Alara deck has for dealing
with somebody suddenly winning is using one of the
two counterspells within the deck, or preparing
to instant-speed sacrifice Child of Alara and
hoping I don’t encounter interaction of any kind.
Okay. So, the Child of Alara dependent game plan
has some holes. Big whoop, I’m playing a gates
deck man, no shit my deck has weaknesses. However,
this is a bigger problem than it seems. Going back
to the idea of the card being asymmetric, we can
think about how it is experienced by the decks
that are more vulnerable to it. And the answer
is it’s hell. It sucks so hard for these decks,
they can barely even start to build a board
before they’re staring down the barrel of
another Child of Alara sac. Even if they deal with
one of my wipes, as long as my ramp game worked
out as intended there will just be another one
immediately following it. This is similar to the
graveyard decks analogy from my last video—this
deck will ruin the day of casual synergy decks,
but against a less board-dependent deck it’ll
putter around and be a mild nuisance before
ultimately getting crushed, with little to no
chance of actually pulling off one of its wincons.
Now, Child of Alara is the most extreme
example of board wipes creating highly
asymmetric game experiences, but this
is an issue with board wipes as a whole.
I talked a bit about my Glissa deck in my midrange
video, and that deck operates as a kind of homage
to the mono black Sheoldred deck I played when
I was 15. Get card advantage and a ton of mana,
and proceed to throw bombs and one-sided board
wipes at the table until my opponents fold.
Now, that deck is much more well-rounded than
the theoretical Child of Alara deck. It has
a lot of single target removal to deal with
key threats, and a variety of wincons which
can all eliminate a threatening player much
faster than Maze’s End or Crackling Perimeter.
Nonetheless, the profile of how it fares
against different decks looks very similar.
I try not to pull out the deck against the low-mid
power midrange decks that make up a decent portion
of decks in my playgroup, because it generally
just stomps on these decks in theatrical fashion.
However, when my opponents have pressure
to prevent me from fully greeding out or
counterspells for my massive mana investments or
combo wins to catch me and my mostly-sorcery-speed
removal suite off guard, it’s much
worse. Against these sorts of plays,
my deck ends up looking like one of the
clunky midrange decks that I usually crush.
Before going further, I should take the
opportunity to state that board wipes aren’t bad
overall. A lot of decks are heavily board-based,
and it’s good to have a solid way to deal with
that. A better version of my Glissa deck would
probably be running 3-5 board wipes instead of 8,
with tutors to bridge the gap, but years spent as
a mono-black player forced me into the hard truth
that unconditional tutors are bland as hell, so
I don’t play them. Ultimately, the deck is what
I want it to be, and I’ll happily let it serve
as a teaching point as happily as I’ll play it.
The real thing I’m trying to convey here is the
need to be mindful when constructing your deck.
The interaction package of your deck, and what
things it’s particularly good or bad against,
is something you should think about.
Ideally, it should be well-balanced,
and if there are holes they should be
intentional rather than incidental.
As an example, my Meria equipments deck has
very little hard removal—burn and noncreature
permanent destruction, yes, but not much for
big creatures. This is mostly a matter of the
fact that I’m playing an aggro deck, and I’m
looking to get a substantial board presence
early and be threatening life totals. The deck’s
removal serves to slow down my opponents and
deal with pesky cards like Trigon Predator,
but ultimately the deck’s solution to later
threats is to simply deal with the player,
or politic around the threat for a while.
My deck’s removal suite has a hole, but it’s
a calculated one. Another common hole in an
interaction suite would be fast blue decks
that choose to almost entirely run counters
that don’t target creatures—a choice motivated by
the fact that most forms of interaction from their
opponents are noncreature, and an essence scatter
isn’t gonna help protect a turn 4 combo win.
As a final note, let’s return to the idea of
asymmetric effects. A lot of stax effects and
hate cards also fall under this label, but stax
effects generally operate the opposite way as
board wipes—choking out burstier strategies
that carefully plan out their resources to
execute a specific gameplan, while having less
of an effect on a deck whose gameplan consists
of “play treefolk” or something. There’s a reason
why running a load of stax effects is a better
idea than running a load of board wipes—the sorts
of decks shut down by an Archon of Emeria are
generally stronger and more carefully constructed
than the sort of decks shut down by a Plague Wind.
You can build a deck with a bunch of stax effects
and a win plan that can outrun a midrange deck,
but you can’t build a deck full of boardwipes
with a win plan that can outrun a combo deck.
And if you build a deck that massacres casual
midrange decks but flails around against
everything else, you’re going to be struggling
to create interesting and dynamic games.